how's it going
and welcome to one day early can you
believe it
I don't it's Halloween today and you
know what that means
it's costume time so Halloween have a
penguin fingers aren't really that scary
unless they twerk good say I don't
I wanted to make a list of the top 10
free horror games now you bros can check
out right now and play with your friends
and have some fun for Halloween number
pain
I put vapor as number 10 I plated not
long ago it was very awesome they did
made an update for the game if you're
scared of old people very close to your
face don't play this game or doing what
the [ __ ]
[Music]
it's it's one of the coolest free horror
games I played in while it's very very
unique very different you'll have fun
playing it for sure not at 9:00
I put stairs on number one I also played
it not long ago and it was made by a
bunch of sweden's dudes so that's always
a plus
you're basically trapped in like a
Content keg
you're basically trapped down underneath
the ground in a shelter it's pretty damn
well made for a free game if you're
really scared it's not too scary so I
think it's a good one to check out if
you're a new like me don't worry we're
not here to judge I'll take a picture
not blood to Instagram [ __ ] love maps
on Instagram number eight for number
eight I put one late-night basically you
play as a guy who is working late and
all the sudden all this scary stuff is
happening in his office [ __ ] goes down
pretty damn fast ones it goes goes down
I feel like the [ __ ] stuck in
this dive it makes me wanna quack like
what the [ __ ] is that it's actually
pretty damn scary if you're there for a
scare beware I have a pair I don't have
a pair I'm sorry Oh number seven I put
eerie it was one of the first really
good free horror games that I played the
sound in that game are so real I
remember when the baby's crying you're
like what the [ __ ] is someone crying
shut that baby up the monster is almost
as sexy as Edgar why can't we do really
perfect for Halloween if you want to
want to scare your tits off and if you
don't have tips you can just take them
on and then probably fall off anyway I
don't know how it's work number six is
which which is which is the great horror
game I remember I played it a long time
ago
and it scare the [ __ ] out of me stop
stop stop
no now stop doing that [ __ ] [ __ ] sir
please I don't know scared as much today
but I remember when I played it it was
really [ __ ] scary for number five
that put bong Chun Doong Doong I
pronounced that right get it's awesome
because I think I don't think a lot of
you bros know about it it's [ __ ]
terrifying I don't want to spoil
anything it's really it's a really
creepy comic that you read my [ __ ]
leg number four number four I put PES
adela or insanity it's made by the same
guy they're both great really like
intense [ __ ] going on all the time and
row counter my sort of cry of fear this
is way about it this is way better very
very scary number three number three I
put seven days slash I'm scared there
are two very similar games they're kind
of pixel horror as I like to call them
they're so subtle and they're so creepy
and it just [ __ ] with your brain
afterwards I don't give a [ __ ] alright
seven days is a little more interesting
in my opinion out of audible for them so
I recommend check that one out
not at all I put haunt it's also called
haunted memories they change a lot of
names I don't know the reason title but
it's on Steam early access it's probably
one of the most polished free hot indie
horror games that I ever played like it
looks better than a lot a lot of paid
products that you get these days
[Music]
number one number one its Kraven Manor
I think that game is super impressive it
was a student project it's it's like 40
minutes to play and it's fun for 40
minutes which I can't really say about
all the games on this list they're kind
of too subtle at some points and you
just get bored I never got bored playing
this game it was so much fun all the way
through and has good puzzles it has a
good story great atmosphere very well
made and it's very scary [ __ ] name just
happened what that [ __ ] was that I don't
even what's going on in hey why did you
just touch me
do it again please I love this I hope
you and check out all these titles there
are a lot of fun nobody bros have a
great Halloween fighting games blend
them with your friends watch me whatever
you do have fun eat a lot of candy
I don't know sorry I wasn't uploading in
the past three days I've been traveling
as you can check out in my vlogs but
thank you as always thank you both so
much for all the support I'll see you in
the next one say awesome you ready
here comes
[Music]
dream
and it's supposed to be like interactive
see it's hard even for me to be happy
either